you know I think if you take Conor
McGregor at his word and read into some
of his social media voice over the last
several months he is Jones and to get
back in the octagon and I think he
understands that urgency there are a lot
of Fighters who don't believe in ring
rust but extended layoffs and mixed
martial arts are just not a good thing
even my boy Dominic Cruz I think would
agree with that and I know Chael Sonnen
obviously recently came out and
suggested that if Conor doesn't compete
in 2023 he'll never compete in the UFC
again I'm not going to go that far
because as I've said to Brendan Schaub
and others I just feel like Conor
McGregor was born to fight if he could
be doing anything it would be competing
in a mixed martial arts setting so I
don't necessarily think he has to
compete this year but I believe without
a shadow of a doubt if his health is
there Conor McGregor is going to compete
in the UFC in 2023 and I would actually
say over two and a half more UFC fights
for Connor I think he's going to
continue to compete and try to get in an
active competition cycle had he not
broken his leg you know he might have
been fighting three times a year this is
what he wants to do I'm hoping he's not
going to make me eat my words